[Musique]
plus d'une quarantaine de partenaires du
monde économique social et public
s'engage au sein du pacte territorial
d'insertion un ensemble de mesures de
dispositifs qui ont pour seul objectif
proposer une solution d'insertion à
chaque foyer bénéficiaire du RSA il faut
savoir écouter savoir dialoguer et
proposer et à l'issue d'un dialogue et
d'une écoute et bien il y a des
propositions soit de formation pour
celles et ceux qui ont besoin de plus de
qualification parfois d'orientation
parfois aussi il faut régler d'autres
problèmes tels que problème de logement
problème de mobilité et une fois que
vous avez créé les conditions de
l'inseration à travers tout cela et bien
l'entreprise prend le relais et là on
fait de l'immersion dans l'entreprise et
on se dit que
l'employeur propose à la personne qui le
qui aura été accompagné et bien cette
inserion soit par un contrat de
travail soit aussi par un contrat de
stage donc ça peut aussi donc des
contrats en alternance mais au bout et
on le sait quand il y a cet
accompagnement qui se fait et qui se
fait bien au bout il y a de bons
résultats le tau de réussite est bon et
c'est pour cela que nous allons
continuer pour suivre et travailler
travailler encore plus dans tous ces
domaines renforcer l'accompagnement
social et l'accès à l'emploi et à la
formation c'est toute l'ambition de
cette stratégie partager agir au plus
près des demandeurs d'emploi proche des
personnes c'est le fameux allé vert
qu'on utilise maintenant plus on est
capable d'entendre leur leurs besoins et
de répondre avec plus de précision et
plus de
rapidité à leur problématique de
logement de mobilité de santé de garde
d'enfant il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont qui sont évoquées 134 millions
d'euros sur 3 ans contribueront à porter
ses mesures d'insertion sur tout le
territoire en faveur de ces bén
[Musique]
offici